hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I got blown up
with messages for Mortal Kombat X tremor
trailer all right I really like Mortal
Kombat X I played it many times I don't
personally own it but I have a best
friend who I guess he's my best friend
well one of my best friends so Kyle
that's what I like to read
[Music]
[Music]
hi please scan your peers in travel
trailers
[Music]
Oh woof national event
well that wall smashing that was freakin
badass [ __ ] love it I can't wait to
play as that guy it's cool to see Trevor
from Special Forces and I believe he was
on MK 9 for PSP it's cool that they're
bringing him back in such a reborn
badass way you would I would really like
to see in the Mortal Kombat games the
[ __ ] terminator that would be the
[ __ ] or the t1000 that would be really
cool too Mortal Kombat guys if you're
listening do it do it anyway guys thanks
for tuning into the channel if you're
new to it you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope
because if we get enough followers on
our social networks we can get even more
product placement for things such as 1up
box 1up box is great I personally am
already doing some product placement for
them that's right me Tyrone Magnus a few
other youtubers you pay a monthly
subscription and they send you a bunch
of cool video game based stuff usually
and it's really cool you get a custom
made t-shirt now look that's great I
love it trust me
but if I can get a box like this you
know kind of like a loot crate the 1up
box kinda thing but for sex toys that
would be awesome
I would love to receive a brand new
dildo every month I want to watch my
girlfriend play with it I want to play
with it that's right people I like
getting tickled down there